ciao ragazzi nostro bella tutti ragazzi
usate non volevo offendere
io volevo registrare maine usa erano
soliti giochi no partita sta roba
un ora che calca e stai caricarsi o film
l'amat ho mica stare calmi 13 sti santa
il pianeta di babbo natale assetato di
sangue si potresti mettermi i titoli di
coda in coda invece in apertura grazie
[Musica]
raga sic io che non ne sbaglia una
devo tradurre pure dicendo che è un
pianeta in abitato vogliamo prendere 4
milionari a testa e tornare alla nave
capisco
capisci aiuto è o no una ricarica evento
per questo pensate dato i movimenti più
fluidi capirà mai visto in un gioco
ricordano un po politici diana o bello è
bellissimo
posso cambiarla visuale a posso anche
avere la madonna volta fatto bene bene
allora devo trovare dei minerali e
lavati santi fa sta tizia beh non c'e la
gravità o meglio c'è la gravità ma è
molto minore rispetto alla terra sotto
l'euro
siamo un gruppo di astronauti dobbiamo
recuperare 4 minerali a testa e tornare
alla
nav è che quella il tizio ha detto che
un pianeta inabitato ci credo molto poco
visto che si chiama il gioco planet il
pianeta di babbo natale assetato di
sangue quindi promesso salve c'è mica un
babbo natale assetato di sangue qua
dentro permesso a quanto tetro rega un
forno
mi fa piacere che ci sia l'ikea anche
sugli altri pianeti raccogliere dei
minerali o dove dormirò questa roba
tra tutti amarante prenderlo si neanche
minecraft rega aim a nastro nout
explorer capisce permesso a hicks
lockeed pure chiuse le porte st
tecnologie aliene le capirò mai
porca eva non un oro europeo da far poi
rivedere il replay bene la politica re
trice i tre vite rimanenti bene ma non
da qua porca eva preferisco i miei
vicini che trapani o guarda così quasi
ma voi non fate un cazzo dalla mattina
alla sera a tutto ciò che tra pan armi
maroni niente pronunciata cosa troppo
all'arte ogni volta in staccata lavoro
spiega del novara che son curioso io mi
immagino da loro casa entra piena di
tutti mentre mi dici di trapano
senza fare il salto decente o le bono
qualche ora perché non guardo dove vado
ma che promette o il cervello ci sono
dei pupazzi di neve grossi molto grossi
1 c'è una tipa papin cosa si sono fumati
quando ha fatto sta roba lo sanno solo
loro però vabbè andiamo di qua perché
già capire sta roba è un casino scanner
futuristi santas village il villaggio di
babbo natale va bene se avete dei
minerali in tutto questo sta chiusa o
questa si apre permesso minerali
minerali per terra grazie molto gentili
eccola con fu un rubino prenderlo si tua
su quattro bene la fabbrica di giocate
ha finalmente permesso
eppure chiusa tra una lettera per terra
perché era ciao babbo stavo stavo le
stavo leggendo una cosa per terra ma è
no aspetta se devo ai mi porti dei
minerali per natale che non bisogna
grazie via via via via via via via
verona aiutami o pazzo inutile allora
che non ho capito cos'era è spuntato
babbo natale dal nulla tipo boogeyman
che voglio andare dove mi va cercare
babbo nata la gara possibile che sti
diamanti rubini o quello che siamo così
incasinati da trovato solo forlì forni e
frighi dall'ikea aliena guidate una
pietra preziosa qualcosa che devo fare i
soldi qua nulla ma mi fosse anche la
moto perfetto perfetto a posto è tratto
lo zaffiro pighi tappe yes
ora che ne abbiamo tre ne manca uno
troviamo quello giusto oggi ha
controllato tutto porca eva morta di
infarto
ma ti pare il quale che nel mondo
dell'universo davis puntarmi così sono
incastrato aiutato di saltare fa l'ho
visto io no no no a giugno magari tn che
nervi dai ragazzi a una se.ga mi fa
ripartire grazie a gesù poi ti spunta in
una maniera che veramente fa quasi
ridere prot
madonna tua madre morta c'è qualcosa che
sta per uccidere una missione una
missione
sì ma dobbiamo essere veloci ci dobbiamo
dividere e così possiamo setacciare più
spazio
l'unico modo userò la mia radio se ho
bisogno di raggiungerti buona fortuna
vabbè che costa faccia acqua non è che
potesse aiutarmi di sa quanto è però a
me interessava l'ultimo minerale invece
ho trovato subito mongoloide c'era una
calza appesa in tutto questo è bello ma
l'ansia di vivere in stoffa viola ma
d'occhio successo qua salve che casino
quante morto qualcuno per cui se prendi
perfetto marco adesso la nave
venne comunque devono sentire adesso no
come tu che continua no dai
no veramente ho portato mezz'ora della
mia vita
pietro ma certo bel kalina di minerali
di merda cosa sono serviti min oltre
un'ora nel mio tempo potevo fare
qualsiasi cosa potevo tirare le
freccette alla foto di pietro che appese
in camera no la spesa giocare sta roba
non siamo neanche tornati sulla nave
tubi continua ebbe tua madre che ha
creato sta roba gesù dio mio
ragazzi miei spero che video vi sia
piaciuto buon natale a tutti e
soprattutto che minchia di materiale il
tour cuore però vabbè ragazzi
[Musica]